which report Minh is one of the UK's
foremost film composers her often quirky
sometimes brooding and always
beautifully elegant scores have
accompanied the films of Roman Polanski
Jonathan Demi Robert Redford Mike Lee
and dozens more
she's one of that rare breed of creative
artists who can adapt to any style but
retain a unique musical voice whether
it's for a breezy comedy like Jacques
Allah a political drama like The
Manchurian Candidate or the prim world
of Emma you just know when it's a Rachel
Portman School she won the Best Original
Score Oscar in 1997 for Emma the first
woman to ever win in that category and
she continues to be ever-present
on the big screen recent projects like
Bellamy never let me go and one day
prove that Portman is still looking for
interesting and often challenging
projects I can't wait to talk to you
Rachael Pullman here in the Elgar room
at the Royal Albert Hall for the first
in this series for BAFTA of
conversations with screen composers I
had a break from Dave Putnam and it was
through Alan Parker who was giving a
talk in one of his films and I I went
along as a student and I gave him after
as I sent him a cassette of this little
film I'd done sort of student film and
he passed it on to David Puttnam who
literally gave him my first job and he
it was a rewrite on a film that was
going to come out on channel 4 at drama
in like three weeks time and he said to
me I'm not completely happy about the
music do you want to have a go and so I
went home and I sort of looked at the
film I came up with a melody and I came
out with this other little audio
cassette with a piano theme on it and
and he said right you're on awfully good
so he gave me a really big break I was
about 21 22
I hadn't really done anything this is
where I work I write on the piano and I
I've got it the the screen sort of
angled so that I can look at the piano
and have ideas at the same time
down erotic pets on paper on the piano
and then I can record and control the
film through my computer here and I use
Pro Tools for that so a typical day for
me is literally just playing sections of
the film that I want to work on
throughout the day and just coming up
with ideas writing them down recording
them which I have I have a very simple
technology but I feel that it works you
know works great for me so I just record
my piano ideas in sync to the film I'm
InterPro tools and then I can play them
back with the film to see if they're
working from that process when I want to
I can I just orchestrate from the piano
from my piano school so I can just all
but put it from Canas go into the you
know orchestral whatever the instruments
are and yeah that's all I really need is
just sort of round me like this I don't
have any synthesizers or anything you
did a lot of television in the 80s
yeah but the decade finished really on
them on a big high didn't it with
oranges are not the only fruit yeah tell
us a little bit about about that project
um well it was a three-part series very
sort of groundbreaking television making
very boldly directed by B van Kidron and
a very bold story to match the extremely
rich text of the story of Jeannette
Winston's
and a bold you know a bold subject and
it was brave and colorful and hilarious
but really sad as well and you know I
had such fun working on it I could
really I threw all sorts of ideas at it
and they stuck and you know it's not
often you get an opportunity with the
script and you know and actors like that
where you can just really you know go to
town on what you want sure I wasn't I
wasn't wanting the music to ever sort of
take over though there were times when
the music was incredibly bold in it and
beeban kidron gave me that freedom to do
that
like most people I live for a long time
with my mother her father my father like
to watch the wrestling my mother liked
to wrestle didn't matter what she was in
the white corner that was that she hung
out the largest sheets on the windiest
days she wanted the moments to knock on
her door
at election time in a labor mill town my
mother put a picture of the conservative
candidate in the window
she'd never heard of mixed feelings her
friends there were enemies
I do like the idea of having a theme and
a melody I've always enjoyed writing
melody and I do think that something
magical happens if you start a melody at
the beginning of a film you know and in
it's able to develop and and it's there
at the end and even though most of the
people watching the film would be
listening to music or even perhaps even
conscious of it it it somehow adds to
the story it's sort of like it's a
mother character
I heard she was some kind of radical
or the composer perform you're not just
matching the scratch and what happens in
it you're also painting the characters
and so they're very specific to the
actual actors and what they're giving
out to you from the screen as to what
you you give back and also the tone of
their voices you know there's a there's
a famous role that was one of the very
first rules I learnt about writing music
for film which is that if you use an
oboe in a similar register because overs
can conflict with voices during dialogue
that's going to be a problem and so you
have to sort of have things higher and
lower if you're going to score over
dialogue and you know it's the tone of
turn of someone's voice will make a
difference just the actual picture of it
so there are lots of things that sort of
guide you to make the choices that you
do I've always felt that my job in
writing the score for a film is to serve
the film and therefore and and I and the
director in particular and the producer
as well but particularly the director
and their voice and what they want and
it can really vary how much they how
much input they'll give you and how much
they'll want to know of what you're
going to do or how much they leave it up
to you or how much they're prepared to
sort of it you know it's and so every
time I start working on a new project
that relationship has to start from if
it's something haven't worked with
before from from the beginning and
writing music for film this it's one of
the it's one of the hardest I think jobs
for a director to give over to somebody
else on a film because they actually
don't know what you're going to do and
and it can't music can be something
really frightening to two directors it's
really the one the one thing that they
they often can't do themselves yeah
exactly they can operate a camera
exactly they know about getting the
nobody acting often how often are actors
yeah but they're not musicians say they
have to sort of it's a terrifying choice
to choose a composer
normally I would begin working on a film
when it's in a sort of rough cut stage
and I would have probably had a few
conversations with the directors before
I've been before I've been hard so at
that point what once the film was in a
rough cut I would be I would receive a
copy of the film and I'd look at it and
then I'd go and spot what's called
spotting the film where the director and
editor usually in the cutting room and I
would bring to the table where I thought
music should be in the film and they
would also probably have a pretty good
sense of where they think music should
be by that stage but often they're
really open to ideas and fortunately
they actually you know they welcome the
input of a composers fresh eye on it
you know I'd spent some time ago on my
own and I would go through the process
of getting to know the film so well I'd
read the book you know in this case I
read the book I would watch the film
until I knew it inside out back to front
and that and and I would start sort of
coming up with ideas sort of but there's
a moment at which I was fine when I'm
you know writing music for film there's
a moment where I actually I need to
cross that threshold to where I'm
actually in the film and I'm living and
breathing it and I become part of it and
then it just all happens naturally but I
definitely stand outside the film whilst
that process is going on you never let
me go I've watched it several times and
tried to get to know it and trying to
cross that barrier where you suddenly
become part of the film and then a
musical idea will come and it's it's
often difficult to pinpoint exactly why
you have a musical idea or why you use a
particular instrument but there was
something in the the character the main
character of Kathy of of the of this
sort of love that she couldn't fulfill
with this young boy I just had this
chord in my head which was like a sort
of chord which wouldn't go away and then
to have a melody always underneath it as
opposed to you know most most
traditional music the melodies on top
and the cause are underneath and I
thought I because I wanted to had this
thing that was held so to have this
melody underneath
by the time Ruth and Tommy actually did
separate my Cara training had already
begun so I was hardly ever at the
cottages
it had never occurred to me that our
lives which had been so closely
interwoven could unravel with such speed
it can take quite a long time until I
feel I've found the musical voice of the
film and the weather that'd be just a
tone or whether it be a melody it can
take a long time to get there and it can
be agonizing sort of waiting and you can
get close to it you get glimpses of it
but it won't be fully formed and
sometimes it's really frustrating
because I'll I'll be working on
something for about a week and it just
won't it just I know that there's
something wrong with it I know I'm
probably in the right ballpark but and
then I find the very best thing to do is
to is to record it put it up against
film put my pen down for the day and
then come back to it the next day and
have a look at it and usually then I
have a pretty clear idea of whether I
need to throw it out
start again which you've got to be brave
enough to do even though the clock is
ticking and you've got less and less
time the theme will come it always does
let's talk about Emma a big success your
Oscar winner of course a first-time
director actually Douglas much yeah
mostly a writer I think before he
directed this film how did you come to
the project he couldn't touch with me
and he'd heard someone musical and
something else I can't remember what it
was but he's a long time again I've
worked with him on everything he's done
since and he's the most wonderful man
and unbelievably particular about what
what he wants music what and how he
wants the music to be not about the
melodies he's always really happy
usually with the themes that I come up
with but but really sort of very precise
and in particularly in comedy and Emma
is a comedy
a firm like EMA which is the period film
I probably unconsciously went to a very
different part of my musical so writing
brain to write music for that because I
was working in a context of a period
film so I wouldn't have needed a
different idiom and the idiom I chose
it's very much my Adeem of what I would
think a period film would would want as
opposed to somebody else's I wouldn't
have wanted to put a piano in that
school
I don't know why that is they played
piano then but it just it just didn't
feel right
so it it's sort of not of the period but
it sort of harkens more back to a sort
of traditional kind of harmony it's
based more on sort of folk dances the
school for Emma and and that sort of
seemed to work with the liked humor of
the film and you know the rural setting
and and the sort of formalities of them
all as well it all seemed to sort of go
without which is why I chose that medium
then of course you have the performances
and with a fantastic central performance
like wind Paltrow's in Emma she gives
you know gives me gave me if the
composer a lot to play with because of
her the way she played it to her humour
and her you know and her pain at times
and her her you know her falling in love
and how much making I'm hugely
influenced by by what I see on the
screen and the tone of her character
well I have to ask you about the Oscar
because of course you won for that score
yes what was that like for you our
experience it was it was amazing it was
like a being invited to a party and
becoming part of a club that you you
know you were just on taking on the
sidelines for it was a total surprise
and I mean it was great they're really
wonderful you were the first woman to
ever win a Best Original Score Oscar so
that that must have meant something to
you
actually it didn't I know
you know didn't I get asked about it
love it no no no no I mean it's just
I've never thought of myself as a as a
female composer but a lot of people will
have seen you on win the Oscar I'm sure
and think you know what actually that's
something that I'd like to do myself so
I'm bound to ask you having been in the
business quite a while now what you
might tell young composers who want to
become film composers I get as much
experience as you can working on student
films theatre is good don't give up if
you really want to because I you know I
had many years in my 20s work with very
very patchy work and sort of like 18
months with nothing and you know it's
hard to break into it it's a different
world now than it was when I broke into
it you know there's there's far more
opportunities to study it now than there
were I mean I didn't study at all and
nor did I really study other composers
you know that you through myself I mean
I was fascinated by film but so I didn't
study the greats either and I think that
it's fantastic to be able to study it
now you can get so much experience and
you know try and find it the young
filmmakers the student filmmakers are
out there and try and work on their
films I would say it's the best way to
get into it I love working at home this
is this studio is in fact my home in my
home and it's slightly improved it's not
perfect if a if a big siren goes past
outside I'll hear it but it's slightly
it sort of cut off one step removed from
the rest of the house and it's great to
work from home because you don't have
any don't waste any time traveling and
if you have a thought in the middle of
the night
you can come running downstairs in this
case this is in the basement I can come
down and and jot ideas down so it's
never that far never that far from my
penny and yeah no no I love working from
home that's worked great for me I sort
of celebrate the fact there's so much
different music on film out there I
think there's too much music on film I
think I wish people use it less I wish I
was able not to have to you know be
encouraged to sort of write music ever
so much yeah I'm always saying actually
a bit less is much better because you
know the music starts people relax they
sit back they don't they you know you
stop the music and they sit forward
again and they and they sort of
concentrate because the sounds that the
musics come out and it's really
important whether where the music comes
out and to let it be out for a while and
then when it comes in again actually has
it it does something it's able to work
it's you know it's magic I'm just I'm
just I'm just a little stuck
sure save us right that makes sense
that's done where do you learn as a
composer how to write it in every style
possible from listening to music I guess
or just absorbing music but I don't know
how to write in every style I mean I
have my own idea of how waters a
particular style would be and you know
Manchurian Candidate it's an interesting
example because it's a very frightening
film and my initial conversations with
Jonathan he said look this is a very
frightening film I think I'd like a very
you know sort of Hitchcockian
in-your-face rugged fear kind of score
and so that's what I did I went off and
wrote you know and this is sort of big
score we recorded a lot of it and then
then he looked and he thought oh my
goodness this is this is not what I
wanted and which was terrifying for me
because the film was going ahead it's a
huge film and everything and and in
searching for direction it's all it's
very very hard for directors to some
directors to give good direction to
composers because isn't they're not
often sure what they want or what their
film needs your judgment someone who
sends but he sent me off on beloved as
well on lots of different sort of to
look for difference and I love that but
in the end I'm a Manchurian Candidate he
said to me what I need is the music to
be viscerally frightening and the minute
he told me that I knew what to do I
don't think I I mean there was nothing I
studied as to how to write music like
that I just tried to write music that
made my made me frightened when I was
writing it listen go to the bedroom of
your suite
enter the whole way there
go to the end and open the closet
yes thank you
hi Raymond hello do you remember me
no sir I don't is it true that give a
film composer six months to write a
score they will take six months but give
them till Saturday and they'll do it by
Saturday yeah yeah that's just the
mindset yeah yeah you just make it fit
you know yeah
there are huge pressures time pressures
in getting a school to the finish line
you know in time and you know it it does
become harder to enjoy the process but
there is always that moment where where
you think I think I've cracked it I
think I've got you I can have a day
where I can completely lose myself where
I've been searching and actually quite
worried that I'm going to come up with a
theme and then I suddenly find it and
I'm exuberant and that's the best
feeling in the world that's why you do
it
who'd you say your main influences well
it sounds weird but probably Bach and
Ravel I don't really have film sort of
influences as much and probably even far
more than anyone who do you admire there
in your own business um I admire John
Williams I don't like everything he does
but I you know I'm not so keen on the
big brush scores but I fortunate list
was really beautiful I'm just trying to
think I think some Morricone is some of
its westerns you know which is fabulous
mostly melodies Nino Rota wonderful do
you have a turn products now because you
just don't like the story yes yeah I do
um I think it's really important to be
selective because you otherwise you can
be matched with something that really
doesn't interest you very much yeah I
think I think it's it is important to to
want to work with interesting directors
to what you where you can and projects
that you that mean something to you
whether it you know even if it's
something small budget over something
large budget if you're writing music
it's got to be a value to you in order
for you to do something that's going to
have your heart and soul in it so I
think it's really important
you